hello everyone this video was a bit
different than what you're used to this
Saturday I went to the pool and I had my
chessboard with me and in between swims
I decided to create my first chest
puzzle and this took me about two or
three days I was trying to really create
a unique puzzle although it's it's a lot
more difficult to then then it seems to
create a chess puzzle but it is managed
to create one so this is the puzzle and
I'm interest to see if you can fold it
black black has to win this game and
this actually a force checkmate in eight
moves for black you can also try a
checkmate in nine moves but either way
I'm interested to see if you can solve
it it's a pretty funky position white is
threatening to promote his pawn here
with check and yeah I dunno okay this
Bishop here it's an impossible position
because how this Bishop gets to h1 if
the g-tube bow never moved I know but
this is it was needed for the puzzle so
I had no no way to avoid this so it's a
puzzle you know it's there to be solved
so I will not show you the solution to
this puzzle I will post the solution
into the description of this video
maybe maybe tomorrow I'll do it tomorrow
so and by then I'm interested to see how
many of you can solve it and well I
don't think it's a difficult puzzle I'm
just you know I'm worried that it's
there it's not too easy to solve so if
you do manage to solve it do do write it
in the comment section below and yeah
that's about it and well I am interested
in your opinion what do you think of the
puzzle is it to do is to difficulties
it's too easy to solve is it's too is
just bad you know so that's about it and
I'm looking forward to seeing how many
of you can fold it so as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here and
that's it thank you for watching and I
will see you guys soon